you draw from all different elements I
was doing Claude Rains from The
Invisible Man
crazy you'll think I'm crazy I'll show
you was crazy so you know when other
kids were studying algebra I was working
on my smarter than the average bear the
way I did it was when I would be in a
record store go to the children's record
section and look at Rocky and Bullwinkle
albums Looney Tunes albums that had the
list of who did what and I would
recognize voices I said okay Huckleberry
Hound he sounds like Andy Griffith
snagglepuss is Bert Lahr I don't stay
fresh and I can fight there was one that
had a particular impact on me and I
think it was before I even started first
grade that's probably five Walt Disney's
TV program pulled back the curtain on
how movies were made probably more than
any other single entity in the 60s and
they'd show you the making of this the
making of that and you'd see the camera
crew and the carpenters in the wardrobe
department
there was one that had a particular
impact on me Clarence Nash this
distinguished-looking man in a suit
doing the voice of Donald Duck a light
bulb went off in my head it made me
really think about the people behind the
voices it's the ultimate character
actors dream because the character actor
disappears into his role and you don't
see the after you see the character will
an animation they do that for you they
cast with their ears not their eyes so
you're going to be able to play
characters you would never get if you
were on camera
[Music]
I was a teenager and just a year out of
college and I got a job on Ana Barbara's
genie which was the teenaged version of
I Dream of Jeannie and I played the
Larry Hagman part this was big for me I
walked in and they were all these idols
from when I was a kid I met Don Messick
and DAWs Butler with Mel Blanc he pretty
much did everybody but to see who all
those wonderful voice actors were I is
something I aspired to to be a cartoon
voiceover actor
[Music]
basically you read the script and say
what's required of my character to make
this story work of course if you have
the director there or even the writers
you can talk to them and then arrive at
a voice sometimes gonna scare you
because I was going in to do a character
where I said well he's very potent so
I'll give him sort of a fed voice I'll
make him a little moist and I'm a I
thought I make I guess I made it from
somewhere in New York and they said we
love what you're doing but we don't like
the lisping thing if you dig that out
and also the Brooklyn thing we don't
want to identify where he's from and he
sounds a little sort of portly or pretty
much they took away everything I had
presented to them but that's part of the
fun I mean you don't have time you can't
go over and have a coffee you're on the
clock
so what you do is you start going
through your little repertoire you know
they'll say a little higher that's good
you know and you arrive it's something
that makes everybody happy because when
they're happy I'm happy the one that I
was most intimidated by was the Joker
because I auditioned thinking there's no
way they could handle the backlash of
Luke Skywalker being this icon of
villainy of course your friends always
point out your actor friends they did I
wouldn't want to follow Jack Nicholson
in anything I want forgot about that
in the old town but you know I but I
thought the only way I can do this is do
my version and it's based on the script
that they gave me and the one drawing of
him he seemed to be all teeth
ooh teeth Iran near the the Blue Meanies
in Yellow Submarine you draw from all
different elements because I was doing
Claude Rains from the Invisible Man
crazy you'll think I'm crazy I'll show
do is crazy I had so much fun doing that
character because he's insane and if
you're insane you're unpredictable and
if you're unpredictable you never boring
and he had that incredible love oh my
god where did that come from so I had
quite an arsenal of laughs in my
repertoire already I said to the
producers I don't want him to have just
one laugh I think his laugh should be
like the colors on a palette where it
reflects his mood and I remember reading
an interview with Frank Gorshin where he
talked about it's not that the Riddler
laughs it's what he laughs at that
defines who he is
so his Riddler's like one of my favorite
comic book villains of all time I love
Frank Gorshin where the line that really
struck me is in the man who killed
Batman that Matt Frewer placed this
two-bit crook who accidentally kills
Batman too everyone believes he's dead
this terrible feeling he's really not
coming
Joker loses the will to live he what his
vers on death row is gone and he says
without Batman crying has no punch line
I thought wow crime has no punch line
like it needs one but Batman
he needs Batman and I had my favorite
Batman Kevin Conroy
when they offer me roles now I said is
Kevin Julian they said yeah he said oh
then I'm in I didn't have to read the
script if Kevin's doing it I'll do it
[Music]
first of all I tried to play him like
I'd never played him before and then you
would look at the script and it would
call for different things there was an
episode where Harley Quinn and poison
ivy team of was sort of a Thelma and
Louise and so jokers left at home
shuffling around in the house you know
so he in that instance he was used for
kind of pathetic comedy so like you say
every project is different that's what
keeps it fresh and interesting so you're
not done with a character well I don't
know you never know that how you treat
everyone is your last job because
there's been some spectacular Joker's
over the years brent Spiner and Kevin
Michael Richardson Jeff Bennett John
DiMaggio and on and on Michael Emerson
and to tell you the truth I listened to
them other oh that was a really good
choice I wish I'd thought of that
because everyone it's like the hamlet of
villains
it'll be endlessly reinterpreted by
actors in the future and I'm just lucky
I got a chance to do it at all I'm not
taking orders from you anymore you will
obey me or this defiant breath will be
your last
fire lord ozai when I read it I thought
this thing's not gonna last cause it's
too smart it's too intellectual doesn't
have the flash bang wallop that seemed
to be what was popular at that time I
got a lot of feedback from parents
saying that I watched this with my my
children and that's the best when you
can be a part of something that appeals
to the entire family much better than
any of us could have imagined and that
was largely due to the writing
I'm trying to remember I remember
looking at the drawing thingy he's got a
very david Hyde Pierce vibe going on
sort of you know Niles crane a little
bit of superiority and entitlement
dubbing is much more difficult because
normally the processes they record your
line and they go off and animate to your
line in this case it's the finished film
and I'm blanking on the name who worked
with me Henry the director he's so good
because he specializes in dubs so he'll
be there with you he'll watch you do a
take and then he'll either add a couple
syllables or subtract a couple of
syllables to make it more synced with
the original animation but again this
guy me is on he's a genius
the script is everything let me read the
script I got a really nice letter from
Lars clever Berg the director where he
was talking about how he saw it as a
Greek tragedy and the Chuck he's an
innocent and how he hopes that the
audience will have some understanding or
some sympathy for him so I thought wow
the fundamental change that made me
really want to do it was unlike the
original he wasn't a serial killers the
personality transposed onto a doll he
was an innocent doll where someone when
maliciously goes in and takes off the
safety measures that totally justified
it it was scary because again I'm sort
of old-school I want Chucky Chucky but
you know you have to serve the script
and then that wouldn't have been that
wouldn't have worked did you have a
particular favorite line from this film
well I love when he says are we having
fun now he doesn't know and I can relate
to that because you know as you get
older you look at your kids
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]